So this is the essence of Bayes Rule,
which I'll give to you to you in a second.
There's some sort of a prior, of which we mean
the probability before you run a test,
and then you get some evidence from the test itself.
and that all leads you to what's called a posterior probability.
Now this is not really a plus operation.
In fact, in reality,
it's more like a multiplication,
but semantically, what Bayes Rule does is
it incorporates some evidence from
the test into your prior probability
to arrive at a posterior probability.
So let's make this specific.
In our cancer example, we know that the
prior probability of cancer is 0.01,
which is the same as 1%.
The posterior of the probability of cancer given
that our test is positive,
abbreviate here as positive,
is the product of the prior
times our test sensitivity, which is
what is the chance of a positive result
given that I have cancer?
And you might remember,
this was 0.9, or 90%.
Now just to warn you, this isn't quite correct.
To make this correct, we also have to compute
the posterior for the non cancer option,
which there is no cancer given a positive test.
And using the prior, we know that P of not C is 0.99.
It's minus P of C
Times the probability of getting a positive test result
given not C.
Realize these 2 equations are the same,
but I exchanged C for not C.
And this one over here takes a moment to computer.
We know that our test gives us a negative result
if it's cancer free, 0.9 chance
As a result, it gives us a positive result
in the cancer free case, with 10% chance.
Now what's interesting is this is about the correct equation
except the probabilities don't add up to 1.
To see I'm going to ask you to compute those,
so please give me the exact numbers
for the first expression
and the second expression written over here
using our example up there.